- This country of the
United States was not built
by those who waited and rested
and wished to look behind them.
Ask not what your country can do for you,
ask what you can do for your country.
All we have built, all we have worked for
would be destroyed in the first 24 hours.
There are some who say
that communism is the wave
of the future, let them come to Berlin.
- He was an American Politician who served
as the 35th President of the
United States of America.
He was assassinated in Dallas,
Texas on November 22nd, 1963.
He continues to rank highly
in polls of the general
public and historians
as one of the greatest
Presidents of all time,
he's John F Kennedy.
And here's my take on his
top 10 rules of success.
Rule Number Two is my personal
favorite and I'm curious
to figure out which one
you guys like the best
and as always, as he's
talking and he says something
really meaningful then
that resonates with you,
please leave it in the
comments below and put quotes
around it so other people can
be inspired as well, enjoy.
(whooshing)
(bouncing ball)
(uplifting music)
- Surely the opening vistas
of space promise high costs
and hardships as well as higher reward.
So it is not surprising
that some would have us stay
where we are a little
longer, to rest, to wait.
But this city of Houston,
this state of Texas,
this country of the United
States was not built by those
who waited and rested and
wished to look behind them.
(applause)
This country was conquered by those who
move forward and so will space.
In the long history of the
world, only a few generations
have been granted to
role of defending freedom
in it's hour of maximum danger.
I do not shrink from this
responsibility, I welcome it.
(cheering)
I do not believe that any
of us would exchange places
with any other people
or any other generation.
The energy, the faith, the
devotion, which we bring to
this endeavor will light our
country and all who serve it.
And the glow from that fire
can truly light the world.
And so my fellow Americans,
ask now what your country can
do for you, ask what you
can do for your country.
(cheering and applause)
My fellow citizens of the
world, ask not what America
will do for you but what together
we can do for the freedom of man.
(cheering)
Finally, whether you
are citizens of America
or citizens of the world,
ask of us here the same high
standards of strength and
sacrifice which we ask of you.
With a good conscience,
our only sure reward, with
history the final judge
of our deeds, let us go
forth to lead the land we
love, asking his blessing
and his help, but knowing
that here on earth,
God's work much truly be our own.
Some say that it is useless
to speak of peace or world
law or world disarmament
and that it will be useless
until the leaders of the
Soviet Union adopt a more
enlightened attitude, I hope they do.
I believe we can help them do it.
But I also believe that we must
reexamine our own attitudes,
as individuals and as a nation.
For our attitude is as
essential as theirs.
And every Graduate of this
school, every thoughtful
citizen who despairs of war
and wishes to bring peace
should begin by looking
inward, by examining his own
attitude towards the
possibilities of peace, towards
the Soviet Union, towards
the course of the Cold War
and towards freedom
and peace here at home.
First examine our attitude
towards peace itself.
Too many of us think it is impossible.
Too many think it is unreal but that
is a dangerous, defeatist belief.
It leads to the conclusion
that war is inevitable.
That mankind is doomed, that
we are gripped by forces
we cannot control, we
need not accept that view.
Our problems are man made,
therefore they can be solved
by man and man can be as big as he wants.
No problem of human destiny
is beyond human beings.
Man's reason and spirit have
often solved the seemingly
unsolvable and we believe
they can do it again.
By why some say the moon,
why choose this as our goal?
And they may well ask, why
climb the highest mountain?
Why, 35 years ago, fly the Atlantic?
Why does Rice play Texas,
we choose to go to the moon.
We choose to go to the moon.
(cheering)
We choose to go to the moon in this decade
and do the other things,
not because they are easy
but because they are hard,
because that goal will
serve to organize and measure
the best of our energies
and skills because that challenge
is one that we're willing
to accept, one we are
unwilling to postpone
and one we tend to win and the others too.
We observe today not a victory of party
but a celebration of freedom,
symbolizing an end as well
as a beginning, signifying
renewal as well as change.
For I have sworn before
you and Almighty God
the same solemn oath,
our forbearers prescribed
nearly a century and three quarters ago.
The world is very different now.
For man holds in his
mortal hands, the power to
abolish all forms of human
poverty and all forms
of human life and yet the
same revolutionary beliefs
for which our forebearers
fought are still an issue
around the globe, the belief
that the rights of man
come not from the generosity of the
state but from the hand of God.
We dare not forget the day that we
are the heirs of that first revolution.
Let the word go forth
from this time and place
to friend and foe alike that
the torch has been passed
to a new generation of
Americans born in this century,
tempered by war, disciplined
by a hard and bitter peace,
proud of our ancient heritage
and unwilling to witness
or permit the slow undoing
of those human rights
to which this nation has
always been committed to which
we are committed to day at
home and around the world.
(cheering)
Let every nation know whether
it wishes us well or ill,
that we shall pay any
price, bear any burden, meet
any hardship, support any
friend, oppose any foe
to assure the survival and
the success of liberty.
- We are confronted
primarily with a moral issue.
It is as old as the
scriptures and as clear as
the American Constitution,
the heart of the question
is whether all Americans are
to be afforded equal rights
and equal opportunities,
whether we are going to treat
our fellow Americans as
we want to be treated.
If an American, because
his skin is dark cannot eat
lunch in a restaurant open
to the public, if he cannot
send his children to the
best public school available,
if he cannot vote for the
public officials who represent
him, if in short, he cannot
enjoy the full and free life
which all of us want,
then who among us would be
content to have the color of his
skin changed and stand in his place?
Who among us would then be
content with the counsels
of patience and delay, 100
years of delay have passed
since President Lincoln freed the slaves.
Yet their heirs, their
grandsons are not fully free.
They are not yet free from
the bonds of injustice.
social and economic oppression.
And this nation, for all
its hopes and all its boasts
will not be fully free until
all its citizens are free.
It is discouraging to read
a recent authoritative
Soviet text on military
strategy and find on page
after page, holy baseless
and incredible claims
such as the allegation that
American Imperialist Circles
are preparing to unleash
different types of war,
that there is a very real
threat of a preventative war
being unleashed by American
Imperialists against the
Soviet Union and that the
political aims and I quote,
of the American Imperialist
are to enslave economically
and politically the European
and other Capitalist countries
and to achieve world domination
by means of aggressive war, unquote.
Truly as it was written long ago,
the wicked flee when no man pursuith.
Yet it is sad to read
these Soviet statements,
to realize the extent
of the gulf between us.
But it is also a warning, a
warning to the American people,
not to fall into the
same trap as the Soviets,
not to see only a distorted
and desperate view of the
other side, not to see
conflict as inevitable,
accommodation as impossible
and communication as nothing
more than an exchange of threats.
No government or social
system is so evil that it's
people must be considered
as lacking in virtue.
As Americans we find Communism
profoundly repugnant,
as a negation of personal
freedom and dignity.
But we can still hail the
Russian people for their
many achievements in Science
and Space and economic
and industrial growth, in
culture, in acts of courage.
Among the many traits the
peoples of our two countries
have in common, none is
stronger than our mutual
abhorrence of war, almost
unique among the major world
powers, we have never been
at war with each other.
And no nation in the history
of the battle ever suffered
more than the Soviet Union
in the Second World War.
At least 20 million lost their lives.
Countless millions of homes
and families were burned
or sacked, a third of the
nation's territory, including
2/3rds of it's industrial base
was turned into a wasteland,
a loss equivalent to the destruction
of this country east of Chicago.
Today, should total war
every break out again,
no matter how, our two countries
will be the primary target.
It is an ironic, but accurate
fact that the two strongest
powers are the two in the
most danger of devastation.
All we have built, all
we have worked for would
be destroyed in the first 24
hours and even in the Cold
War, which brings burdens and
dangers to so many countries,
including this nation's
closest allays, our
two countries bear the heaviest burdens.
For we are both devoting
massive sums of money to weapons
that could be better devoted to
combat ignorance, poverty and disease.
We are both caught up in a
vicious and dangerous cycle
with suspicion one side
breeding suspicion on the other.
And new weapons begetting counter weapons.
In short, both the United
States and its allays
and the Soviet Union and
its allays have a mutually
deep interest in a just and genuine peace
and in holding the arms race.
Agreements to this end are
in the interests of the
Soviet Union, as well as ours.
And even the most hostile
nations can be relied
upon to accept and keep
those treaty obligations
and only those treaty
obligations which are in
their own interest so let
us not be blind to our
differences but let us also
direct attention to our
common interests and
the means by which those
differences can be resolved
and if we cannot end now
our differences, at least we can
help make the world safe for diversity.
For the separation of church
and state is absolute.
For no Catholic fellow
would tell the President,
should he be Catholic how to act.
And now Protestant Minister would tell his
parishioners for whom to vote.
Where no church or church
school is granted any public
funds or political preference
and where no man is
denied public office
merely because his religion
differs from the President
who might appoint him
or the people who might elect him.
I believe in an America
that is officially neither
Catholic, Protestant, nor
Jewish, where no public
official either requests
or accepts instructions
on public policy from
the Pope, the National
Counsel of Churches or any
other Ecclesiastical source.
For no religious body
seeks to impose its will,
directly or indirectly
upon the general populous
or the public acts of its
officials and where religious
liberty is so indivisible
that an act against one
church is treated as an act against all.
For while this year, it may
be a Catholic against who
the finger of suspicion is pointed.
In other years it has been
and may someday be again,
a Jew or a Quaker or a
Unitarian or a Baptist.
It was Virginia's Harassment of
Baptist Preachers, for example that led
to Jefferson's Statute
of Religious Freedom.
Today I may be the victim,
but tomorrow it may be you.
To those nations, who would
make themselves our adversary,
we offer not a pledge but
a request that both sides
begin anew the quest for peace.
Before the dark towers
of destruction unleashed
by science, engulf all humanity in
planned or accidental self destruction.
We dare not tempt them with weakness.
For only when our arms are
sufficient beyond doubt
can be we be certain
beyond doubt that they
will never be employed
but neither can two great
and powerful groups of
nations take comfort from
our present course, both
sides overburdened by the cost
of modern weapons, both
rightly alarmed by the steady
spread of the deadly atom,
yet both racing toward
that uncertain balance
of terror that stays
the hand of mankind final war.
So let us begin anew,
remembering on both sides
that civility is not a sign of weakness
and sincerity is always subject to proof.
Let us never negotiate out of fear
but let us never fear to negotiate.
(cheering)
Let both sides explore
what problems unite us
instead of belaboring those
problems which divide us.
Let both sides for the
first time, formulate
serious and precise
proposals for the inspection
and control of arms and
bring the absolute power
to destroy other nations
under the absolute
control of all nations.
(applause)
Let both sides seek to
invoke the wonders of science
instead of it's terrors, together
let us explore the stars,
conquer the deserts, eradicate
disease, tap the ocean
depth and encourage the arts and commerce.
Let both sides unite to heed
in all corners of the earth
the command of Isaiah to
undo the heavy burdens
and let the oppressed go
free and if a beach head of
cooperation may push back
the jungle of suspicion,
let both sides join in
creating a new endeavor,
not a new balance of power but a new world
of law where the strong are just
and the weak, secure
and the peace preserved.
All this will not be finished
in the first 100 days,
nor will it be finished
in the first 1,000 days,
nor in the life of this
administration, nor even perhaps
in our lifetime on this
planet but let us begin.
(applause and cheering)
In your hands, my fellow
citizens, more than mine
will rest the final success
or failure of our course.
There are many people in
the world who really don't
understand or say they don't,
what is the great issue
between the free world
and the Communist world.
Let them come to Berlin.
(cheering)
There are some who say,
there are some who say
that Communism is the wave of the future.
Let them come to Berlin.
(cheering)
And there are some who say
in Europe and elsewhere,
we can work with the Communists,
let them come to Berlin.
(cheering)
And there are even a few
who say, that it's true
that Communism is an evil system
but it permits us to economic progress.
Lass' sie nach Berlin kommen.
Let them come to Berlin.
(loud cheering)
Freedom has many difficulties
and Democracy is not perfect.
But we have never had to
put a wall up to keep our
people in, to prevent
them from leaving us.
All free men, wherever
they may live, are citizens
of Berlin and therefore,
as a free man, I take pride
in the words, Ich bin ein Berliner.
(cheering and applause)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Natalie Moses asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want
me to profile next, leave
it down in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
what did you learn in this
video from JFK, what was
the best rule for you?
What are you going to apply
to your business or your life?
Please leave it in the comments
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Antonio from Real Men Real Style.
Antonio, thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book and sending that tweet out.
It really, really,
really means a lot to me
that you support me, so
thank you guys so much
for watching, I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever Your One Word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
(whooshing)
(basketball dropping)